[Music]
michaela is with us in new york city hi
michaela how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so
yeah me and my husband we got married
last year in march 2020 and our first
goal was to pay off my husband's
dividend debt and credit card
which was uh 28 000 and that was it
together we live here in long island new
york and i have some students that
oversee
so i'm originally from sweden
uh and i have a 29 5 thousand
student loan but my interest rate is
zero point zero five okay which means
that
right now i only pay twelve dollars a
year and i'm not taking any further
loans so it's
so you want to keep it like it's a pet
because it doesn't eat much
now the dilemma is that we want to start
a family in the near future and we live
in a one-bedroom apartment
and um yeah we are just debating if we
should no debate pay it off pay it off
pay it off don't start a family while
you're still chained to something
overseas
yeah let's get that paid off possibly if
you have a baby before the student loan
uh is gone and before you have the money
to move into a different property uh
then just move to a two bedroom
yeah we have eighteen thousand saved up
right now oh good how much is the
student loan
twenty nine five uh twenty nine oh good
we only got ten thousand left so pay
eighteen on the student loan today
pay it off are you there
it is it is but here's what's going to
be real emotional when you start your
family with
chained to nothing yeah here's the thing
the question you're really asking us is
what is the shortest distance between
where i am today
and being stable financially and wealthy
financially and the shortest distances
don't screw around with a student loan
and keep it around like it's a freaking
pet you have to kill that thing
and get rid of it and that will give you
more stability and a shorter distance to
wealth and stability financial peace for
you and your family than keeping it
around and it's in the closet growing
and munching over there
and just chomping like some kind of
monster in the closet like some kind of
cartoon or something and no no no no no
no clean up your life
when you have no payments
you feel different physically
when you have no payments your
relationships are changed when you have
no payments your mind is clearer to make
better decisions
you're a better mom
no question about it and uh it's not to
say if you're a bad mom if you have debt
no don't give me those stupid tweets
but the uh but the point is i mean when
you when your mind is clear and free of
the anxiety and the stress associated
with debt it opens you up to be a better
husband better wife better employee
better better version of you you sleep
better you eat better you just walk
through life better yeah right and
that's what we want for you and yes
you're going to have another year of
saving for a house and that's okay
you got plenty of time